vélo attitude qui va arriver à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce samedi 13 mai
c'est avec vous qu'on en parle Jérémy je
voulais conseiller municipal en charge
du développement de la pratique du vélo
pour la commune ça se passera au gymnase
Coubertin de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
alors cette journée Jérémy jugler va
s'articuler autour de 4 thématiques on a
je m'informe je découvre je m'équipe et
j'entretiens oui tout à fait alors on
voit bien à travers les différents
reportages déjà que les Yvelines sont
une terre de vélo
moi mon rôle là-dedans c'est de
développer la pratique pour les
habitants de de Montigny et des
alentours de 50 ans en Yvelines et donc
au bout de trois ans de mandat on a vu
qu'il fallait apporter des réponses
concrètes aux habitants aux questions
qui se posent donc il se pose de
questions pour quelles sont les
itinéraires cyclables comment je puis je
peux protéger mon vélo comment je dois
m'équiper comment je dois réparer
entretenir mon vélo et donc ce sont
thématique que l'on a regroupé dans un
événement à Pierre de Coubertin avec nos
partenaires donc les institutionnels
vivent agglomération départements et
toutes nos associations qui sont
formidables et qui œuvrent au quotidien
avec nous la pratique du vélo et très
importante à Montigny-le-Bretonneux oui
j'espère qu'elle sera de plus en plus
on a la chance enfin on a la chance
c'est un travail de longue haleine
d'avoir été de deuxième au baromètre des
villes de cyclables donc ça c'est un
baromètre national qui est dans lequel
de chacun peut répondre et à Montigny et
deuxième et donc ça sachant que la
première et Versailles
et une grosse ville c'est une grosse
ville dans les Yvelines donc ça confirme
bien les Yvelines comme terre de vélo et
donc là dedans on voit qu'il y a une
vraie
infrastructure il y a des choses qui se
passent il y a des services qui sont
disponibles pour le pour les habitants
mais ils ne savent pas encore
et donc c'est à travers cet événement
qu'on veut les faire venir pour qu'il
découvre parce que on est enfin j'ai
personnellement une conviction c'est à
partir du moment où on a essayé on va le
pratiquer et donc on va répondre aux
questions et on va pouvoir pratiquer il
y aura des vélos à disposition notamment
les vélos de la Vélo Station qui sont en
location normalement pour pouvoir
essayer mais il y aura aussi des vélos
électriques où on pourra faire une
petite pratique et pour vraiment
compléter le dispositif on va organiser
avec notre partenaire du Vélo Club de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux des balades des
balades dans tout pour découvrir nos
pistes cyclables les trajets sécurisés
et donc d'essayer d'essayer c'est
l'adopter alors c'est de plus en plus en
vogue vous proposez également un atelier
de réparation de vélo avec l'association
vicyclette oui tout à fait parce que le
notre
notre démarche elle est évidemment
écologique tourner vers les mobilités
mais elle est également dans une
démarche sociale et de transmission donc
on a pu accueillir l'atelier la
bicyclette là depuis le depuis le 1er
juin à Montigny-le-Bretonneux ça marche
très très fort il y a 150 adhérents qui
se sont inscrits depuis le 1er juin
l'objectif c'est de assurer la
transmission que chacun soit capable de
réparer son vélo de l'entretenir ses
freins sont dérailleur sa chaîne ou
encore
réparer un pneu ou une chambre à air et
d'ailleurs on le voyait sur ces images
même notre journaliste Julien Leroy a
testé l'atelier de réparation
bicyclette comment ça se passe
concrètement concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'il faut savoir pour pouvoir bien
réparer son vélo est-ce qu'il y a il y a
trois choses importantes à connaître
pour entretenir son vélo
alors vérifiez ces freins
vérifiez ces freins parce que ça c'est
très important vérifiez ses pneus et
puis
venir faire un tour à la bicyclette pour
voir comment comment on entretient sa
chaîne et donc
continuant cette journée à la fin à
partir de 20h vous projetez le
documentaire why oui cycle pourquoi nous
faisons du vélo en français de quoi ça
parle ce documentaire
la projection débutera à 20h donc on va
convier tout le monde à partir de 19h30
là c'est aussi une volonté un peu plus
décalée de s'inspirer de ce qui se fait
ailleurs et donc why call c'est un
documentaire sur la société néerlandaise
qui nous explique d'où elle est partie
elle était tout voiture dans les années
70 il y a eu un événement marquant qui a
complètement retourné la société
peut-être que la transition écologique
sera notre événement marquant à nous et
qui à partir de là ils ont développé une
pratique du vélo et ce documentaire va
jusqu'à nous dire mais qu'est-ce que ça
apporte à l'individu et qu'est-ce que ça
apporte à la société comment on fait
société ensemble et comment la pratique
de cet objet tout banal le vélo
finalement change notre rapport à la
société j'ai envie de poser cette
question est-ce que vous faites beaucoup
de vélo Philippe camp Alison Laurent
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
faites au quotidien ou en loisir non la
marche la marche c'est bien aussi moi
pareil je suis plutôt marcheuse
parce que j'habite à 50 mètres de mon
lieu de travail donc le vélo c'est un
peu superflu par contre mon époux fait
énormément de vélo il se déplace par
exemple et l'enseigner à Lille et donc
il ira à vélo à la gare du Nord pour
prendre le TGV par exemple Versailles
gare du Nord
ce type de trajet donc on est plutôt
convaincu c'est juste que j'ai les moins
besoin
je profite pour rebondir parce que c'est
ça ça va tout à fait dans le cadre de la
de l'initiative menée par la région des
RER vélo qui sont pour faciliter les
transitions jusqu'à Paris et entre
banlieue de développer des itinéraires
sécurisés et plutôt rapide et à Montigny
on a deux itinéraires qui passent un qui
vient de Paris Massy et qui va aller
jusqu'à plaisir et à cette occasion on
va développer une passerelle au-dessus
de la de la route donc ça c'est ça va
arriver là dans les années à venir et
puis l'autre itinéraire qui viendront
bouillir qui va aller jusqu'à Paris pour
pour faire ce RER vélo et donc là toute
la collectivité enfin toutes les
collectivités que ça soit la région
l'agglomération le département et la
ville on est complètement mobilisé pour
développer ses itinéraires et bien merci
beaucoup Jérémy jonglais d'avoir accepté
notre invitation si vous êtes intéressé
la vélo attitude c'est ce samedi au
Centre sportif Pierre de Coubertin à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux de 14h à 18h
l'après-midi sera suivi de la projection
d'un documentaire et d'une table ronde à
partir de 19h30 pour plus d'informations
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site
internet de Montigny 78 point fr